una victoria agridulce un tribunal
neerlandés condenó a tres hombres dos
rusos y un ucraniano a cadena perpetua
luego de ser acusados de haber
desempañado un papel clave en el derribo
del vuelo mh17 de malicia Airlines el 17
de julio de 2014 en territorio ucraniano
el cual dejó un saldo de 298 muertos
el tribunal califica los hechos que se
consideran probados como conspiración
para derribar deliberada e ilegalmente
un avión que se sabía llevaba civiles
los acusados fueron responsables de la
coautoría de múltiples cargos de
asesinatos durante el juicio un cuarto
sospechoso fue absuelto sin embargo es
poco probable que los condenados cumplan
sus penas ya que están prófugos de la
justicia el proceso judicial fue
realizado en Países Bajos ya que el
Boeing 777 despegó desde amsterdam en su
ruta hacia kuala lumpur investigadores
de distintas nacionalidades examinaron
registros de teléfonos móviles las redes
sociales y los restos del avión entre
los cuales encontraron una esquirla en
el cuerpo de una víctima que reveló el
tipo y el modelo del arma utilizada
según el tribunal esto significa que la
participación rusa es Clara
muchos de los familiares de las víctimas
de todo el mundo se desplazaron a
ámsterdam para asistir al veredicto del
tribunal
todo el mundo se sintió aliviado
me siento aliviada siento que el proceso
ha llegado a su fin y ha sido muy justo
meticuloso completo y se ha sopesado la
evidencia y siento que ahí está la
verdad
Moscú ha negado desde 2014 cualquier
participación o responsabilidad en el
derribo del mh17 los acusados fueron
juzgados sin asistir al juicio y solo
uno se declaró inocente a través de los
abogados que contrató para que lo
representaran